So Donald Trump has been freaking out on Twitter,
melting down since last night, highly triggered by
the Senate results, and Trump again raising this
idea of huge dumps of votes. The guy can't behave
normally for five minutes. And Donald Trump
even in advance of last night's results,
which we actually knew relatively quickly,
all things considered, tweeting around 10:00
p.m. last night, looks like they are setting up a
big voter dump against the Republican candidates
waiting to see how many votes they need. And
of course, this never happened. Donald Trump,
whatever massive dumps he was involved in or
believed were coming, it just never happened from
the standpoint of the race. And in fact, Democrats
were winning. Early Trump scenario is always
Republicans are way ahead and then massive dumps
come in. And then Democrats when Democrats were
winning early and then the race has tightened
as more votes were counted. And then it was just
slow, slow, slow, steady vote counts going one
way and the other. And eventually it became clear
that Democrats would win by a small margin
in both races because outstanding votes were
overwhelmingly from very, very blue areas, areas,
areas that went three to two for the Democratic
challengers, even even three to one in some
cases. So no massive dumps, no small dumps,
just an election that was counted. And and it was
all pretty unremarkable from the standpoint of
election integrity and counting. And it really set
Trump off. And he spent most of the night tweeting
and retweeting stuff, tweeting at midnight
Eastern and then at 1:00 a.m., calling on Mike
Pence to steal him the presidency saying, quote,
If Vice President Mike Pence comes through for us,
we will win the presidency. Many states want to
decertify the mistake they made in certifying
incorrect and even fraudulent numbers in a
process not approved by their state legislatures,
which it must be. Those are all lies, by the way.
And Trump adds, Mitt can send it back. That won't
happen. Mike Pence reportedly explaining to Trump
yesterday, I can't overturn the results. And we'll
talk a little bit about that later based on a
very good New York Times report. But finishing up
with the Trump meltdown. Then this morning, again,
Donald Trump just out of control, first attacking
reporter Chuck Todd as Sleepy Eyes. Chuck Todd is
so happy with the fake voter tabulation process
that he can't even get the words out straight.
Sad to watch. And Trump's anger knows no limits.
He will attack anybody for anything at any time
when he's melting down again, claiming, quote,
states want to correct their votes, which they now
know were based on irregularity, irregularities
and fraud, plus corrupt process, never received
legislative approval. All Mike Pence has to do is
send them back to the states and we win. Do it,
Mike. This is a time for extreme courage. And
behind the scenes, there are reports that Trump
is reportedly going to absolutely turn on his
own. Vice President Mike Pence. If Pence doesn't
do something today, when the vote count starts,
which we will be covering live, and then
apparently realizing that the Senate is lost.
Donald Trump sending out an all caps tweet this
morning saying the Republican Party and more
importantly, our country needs the presidency more
than ever before. The power of the veto suggesting
Democrats will have the House, Democrats will
have the Senate. You need me there to veto the
things that they will do. Truly crumbling before
our very eyes, the Republican Party collapsing
around Donald Trump. And we we essentially have
to see what else he breaks on the way out. Whoa,
my microphone. They're flipping out there. We have
to see what else he breaks on the way out. As I've
said before, there's a reason that many companies
will escort folks out when their position has been
terminated right away, and it's to prevent
them from doing damage on the way out. And,
of course, Donald Trump having months during
which he can do that damage. So later today,
we will talk about the conversation
where Mike Pence had to explain to Trump,
I can't just overturn the results. We will talk
about what to expect over the next few days.
Let me know your reaction to
the Democratic wins in Georgia.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman, The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.